[Music]
tony robbins garbage too is you know
fill her cup give her what she needs you
know
and then these guys start to think about
oh well i've put relationship equity
into this
yes and and relationship equity is
always a failing strategy particularly
in 2020
when a woman doesn't care about that
doesn't need that as much
and does not and has been taught not to
appreciate that
as much and certainly not in the terms
of
well i he's a great guy why am i why do
i not
feel like i want to have sex with him
why do i you know he he's fantastic he's
a great father
he he does the homework with the kids he
gets them to school on time he does all
this great stuff
but i don't have any lust for him i
don't have any arousal for him but i
really do my personal trainer over here
and i'd really like to get with this guy
and women will be very confused about
that they're like a lot of people like
sort of mistake that that's malice like
oh i'm gonna i'm gonna have him over
here and i'm gonna go bang this guy
who's my
my personal trainer over here it's not
usually women are like i don't know i
don't know why i feel this way
people will try to find myself roll up
yeah yeah i mean
i need to heal myself it's the same
thing that i was talking about in the
will smith video that i
the very popular will smith video that's
what she did
she had to heal herself because she
didn't want to be with i got an
entanglement with
uh august or everything yes yeah so will
smith is a great guy i
i like will smith i do i really feel bad
for the dude
like i've never seen him more beta but
she's banging this guy who's like 23
years old and hot and fun and on top of
his game
and yeah of course that's what she wants
to get with she can't even tell
she can't even she can't be honest with
herself because she doesn't realize it
herself
that that's really what she's after
that's really what she wanted to get
with
and now she feels bad for it because
everybody on planet earth thinks will
smith is a great guy
and so if they think he's getting
screwed by her
that looks bad on her and so now she's
got to make up all kinds of
the hamster wheels start spinning
you